film criticism is definitely worthwhile
but let's be honest here
sometimes critics get so caught up in
whether or not a movie is good that they
stop considering whether it's fun to
watch and yes there is a difference from
swashbuckling adventure to action-packed
sci-fi here are some movies that the
critics despised that are actually
pretty awesome if you haven't seen them
yet beware of spoilers ahead hook it
seems like everybody hates hook film
critics have savaged this 1991 Peter Pan
story as embarrassingly excessive
bloated and a huge disappointment and
it's widely considered to be Steven
Spielberg's worst film but maybe that's
because all those critics have grown up
and forgotten what it's like to have an
imagination granted hook is nowhere
close to being one of Spielberg's best
but for a film about childhood it deals
with some surprisingly mature themes
like unrequited love and the
inevitability of death the story stars
of Robin Williams playing Peter Pan as
an adult who changed his name started a
family became a lawyer and totally
forgot about his adventures in Neverland
until his children were kidnapped by
Captain Hook it's a film about
dysfunctional families and abandoned
kids and according to Evans safe Hawk of
birth movies death hook was a very
personal movie for Spielberg a reaction
to his fear is that his heavy workload
was robbing him of time with his
children in addition to the deep stuff
that's going on behind the surface Hook
is pure Spielberg II and entertainment
the sets which are quite obviously sets
are grand ornate and wonderfully
larger-than-life which is fitting for a
story that was first staged play plus
you can't deny that Bob Hoskins Maggie
Smith and Dustin Hoffman are absolutely
perfect in their parts and the score by
John Williams is pure magic alien 3 when
first-time director David Fincher was
hired for alien 3 the movie was already
behind schedule
there wasn't a finished script and the
studio had lost several million dollars
on the project were still venture was
severely hampered by micromanaging
producers Fox and when the film clocked
in around three hours long the studio
forced him to cut about 30 minutes of
material as a result of that bad
experience ventured disavowed the 19
to film but he wasn't the only one who
hated alien 3 fans and James Cameron are
still furious about the deaths of Hicks
and Newt and most critics panned the
film with many saying it was style over
substance it's true that alien 3 puts a
lot of emphasis on atmosphere but at the
same time that's what makes it one of
the most fascinating movies of Fincher's
storied career set in a dreary wasteland
that screams Mad Max this third
installment is a dark grungy and
beautifully barren cinematic nightmare
Sigourney Weaver is at the top of her
game here playing a more cynical Ripley
who bravely comes to terms with her
inevitable fate true the xenomorph
effects look a little janky and the
forest edits take away from the overall
story but despite the drawbacks alien 3
is a visually brilliant world of
criminal monks and fiery hell escapes a
film that could have been the perfect
ending for a landmark series national
treasure 2004's national treasure was
described by critics as rancid cinematic
cheese with almost nothing recommended
but that's more than a little bit harsh
the film follows Nicolas Cage as
Benjamin Franklin gates a historian who
learns that there's a treasure map
hidden on the back of the Declaration of
Independence
unfortunately fellow treasure hunter Ian
Howe played by Sean Bean decides to
steal the Declaration forcing Ben and
his sidekick Riley to break into the
National Archives and get their hands on
the document first with the Declaration
in hand Ben sets out across the stomping
grounds of America's founding fathers
solving riddles and doing his best to
avoid a barrage of bullets he it's easy
to argue that cage was miscast as the
swashbuckling lead of a popcorn
adventure flick and somebody definitely
should have realized there were 56
signers of the Declaration of
Independence not 55 but national
treasure really shines what our heroes
are puzzling over codes and trying to
piece together clues
there's invisible ink hidden ciphers and
glasses invented by Benjamin Franklin
not to mention conspiracies involving
the Masons and the Knights Templar plus
Sean Bean Diane Kruger and Harvey Keitel
are all fun to watch as they help and
hinder cage in his quest to find the
world's biggest pile of gold
Robocop remaking a classic is always in
that pill battle especially when that
classic is a beloved sci-fi masterpiece
like Robocop Jose Padilla is 21st
century remake doesn't stand a chance
against Paul Verhoeven's 1987 original
but the 2014 version is definitely a
film with its own style and its own
ideas Joel Kinnaman stars as Alex Murphy
a Detroit cop who's been mortally
wounded by a car bomb with his corpse
mangled beyond recognition
he's the perfect candidate for an
experimental program that turns him into
a cybernetic super cop naturally there
is more going on with the Robocop
program than meets the eye
and soon enough Murphy sets out to bring
down the big bads dead or alive
admittedly Kinnaman often has even less
emotion than Peter Weller and the pg-13
rating means that the originals
over-the-top violence has been toned
down considerably in the name of making
a buck still the 2014 film is
surprisingly thoughtful focusing on the
widespread use and danger of drone
warfare and the increasing
militarization of urban police forces
the satirical news sequences from the
original have been swapped out with Fox
News style segments featuring an angry
samuel l.jackson and there's an
interesting update to Alex Murphy's
character arc in the 1987 film Murphy
starts off as a cold blooded cyborg who
slowly regains his humanity but padilla
puts a nice twist on the story with an
emotional Murphy becoming more and more
machine as the movie goes on losing his
ability to connect with others the film
also grapples with heady concepts like
free will and while it lags in a few
places
it features an amazing in the dark
shootout and a truly horrific sequence
where Alex Murphy sees what's left of
his body after a near-fatal explosion
it's never going to replace the original
but
I'd buy that for a dollar
the last Boy Scout Tony Scott's the last
Boy Scout had an infamously troubled
production thanks in part to the
enormous number of rewrites that
screenwriter Shane Black was forced to
make as a result were left with a movie
that's messy disjointed and nowhere near
as tight as blacks other work like
Lethal Weapon or the nice guys that said
while it might be a little jumbled the
last Boy Scout is a fascinating slice of
action cinema a movie full of insane
little moments involving car bombs
helicopter blades and foul mouthed cat
puppets it starts off with one of the
most compelling openings you'll ever see
in an action movie with a drug-addled
football player pulling a pistol in the
middle of a game from there we're
introduced to our heroes cynical private
investigator Joe Hallenbeck played by
Bruce Willis and has been quarterback
Jimmy Dix
played by Damon Wayans investigate the
brutal murder of Dix's girlfriend a
dancer played by Halle Berry as the duo
dig deeper into the case they uncover a
plot involving gambling in the NFL but
what's really important here is that
Shane blacks dialogue is still as clever
as ever and the dynamic between Willis
and Wayans is crackling with frenemy
energy
leather pants
yeah it has more than a bit of a problem
when it comes to its female characters
but on the positive side Taylor Negron
shows up as one of the very best Shane
black villains and were treated to a
scene in which Bruce Willis murders a
dude with the palm of his hand
anaconda with a 38 percent approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes 1997 s
anaconda is generally considered pretty
awful critic Mick LaSalle slammed the
film by saying anaconda is about a snake
that eats everybody that about says it
all timeout London's review added that
the snake doesn't just eat people it
screams Steve Newton of the Georgia
Strait also piled on writing just to
show early on how much danger these
folks are in we get to see the film's
titular star squeeze a black panther so
tight that one of its eyeballs pop out
we're not really seeing why this is a
problem that's exactly the kind of stuff
that makes anaconda so amazing if you go
into the movie expecting something
classy you might walk away disappointed
but if you're expecting the best b-movie
ever then you left the time of your life
it's the kind of movie where a guy
falling from a waterfall gets snatched
out of the air by a snake hanging from a
tree branch and where you can watch a
guy gets swallowed alive from inside the
Anaconda itself in addition to the
killer creatures there's Jon Voight as
Paul Cerrone a mad man who chews up all
the scenery in sight every one of his
lines isn't over-the-top Jim and he
strangles somebody with his own legs
before dousing Jennifer Lopez with a
bucket of monkey blood what's not the
love Snow White and the Huntsman 2012's
Snow White and the Huntsman has been
accused of being putrid and seemingly
endless strange and solace and
underwhelming with a woeful script but
it's worth watching for the visuals
alone directed by Rupert Sanders this
gritty fantasy has images on par with
something you might see at a movie
directed by Guillermo del Toro there's
the battle where Knights fight an army
of soldiers made of glass or the scene
when Queen Ravenna bathes herself in a
milky brew right after munching out of
bird's hearts a White Stag bursts into a
thousand butterflies
and after turning into a flock of Ravens
ravenna crawls from a pit of black ooze
surrounded by the fluttering of dying
birds with sequences like these Snow
White in the Huntsman is equal parts
dreamland and nightmare fuel and it
doesn't hurt that Charlize Theron throws
herself into playing the world's most
evil witch cranking up the volume and
turning on the terror every time she
walks on screen while throne is
wonderfully nuts his Queen Ravenna
Kristen Stewart the most underrated
actress in Hollywood anchors the film
with a much more realistic and
empathetic performances Snow White even
Chris Hemsworth steps up his acting game
and while it would have been preferable
if they used actual little people the
dwarfs are played by some of the very
best British character actors like Bob
Hoskins Nick Frost and Ian McShane and
they lighten things up every time they
appear sure it doesn't compare to the
Walt Disney classic but then it's not
really trying to this is a snow-white
movie that's more about the dark side of
fairy tales the blood the mud the horror
and the Wonder Clash of the Titans with
reviews like New York magazines which
said it isn't a train wreck a train
wreck would be memorable
2010's Clash of the Titans wrapped up a
miserable 28 percent rating on Rotten
Tomatoes and went down as a mistake of
mythological proportions even the star
Sam Worthington said the movie let down
some people but honestly if the critics
didn't like it that might have been
because they lost their sense of fun
Clash of the Titans is a good old
fashioned b-movie a throwback to a time
when Hollywood made adventure flicks
that could charm you with crazy
creatures over-the-top set pieces and a
whole lot of imagination the story
itself is pretty simple
mankind is getting sick of the gods
bossing them around so they decide it's
time to rebel naturally the gods don't
approve
so they threatened to unleash the
monstrous Kraken the human King doesn't
sacrifice his daughter
desperate the King turns to a demigod
named Perseus asking him to find a way
to kill the Beast
along the way Perseus encounters a
murderous Medusa some oversized
scorpions and a trio of witches ease ifs
between towers on a Pegasus teams up
with a group of desert dwelling Djinn
and is forced to deal with all-powerful
gods like Liam Neeson's Zeus and Hades
played by ray Fiennes who turned the
Shakespeare up to 11 mix that in with a
bunch of monsters and magic and you can
see how Clash of the Titans is exactly
the kind of movie that might inspire the
next charge Lucas to make the next Star
Wars thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]